potassium sorbate and they give us its
formula right over here has a molar mass
of 150
grams per mole they put this decimal
here to show us that these are actually
three significant figures even the zero
is a significant digit here is commonly
added to diet soft drinks as a
preservative a stock solution of
potassium sorbate dissolved its aqueous
solution here of known concentration
must be prepared a student titrates 45
milliliters of the stock solution with
1.25
molar hydrochloric acid using both an
indicator and a ph meter
the value of ka for sorbic acid is 1.7
times 10 to the negative fifth
all right so let's tackle this piece by
piece
write the net ionic equation for the
reaction between potassium sorbate and
hydrochloric acid
all right so first i'll just write the
ionic equation and then we'll i'll write
the net ionic equation and hopefully
you'll see the difference so ionic
ionic
equation
and the way we think about ionic
equations is we think about well if
these are dissolved in water it's an
aqueous solution these are going to
disassociate into their into ions and so
we would write that out on both the on
both the reactant and the product side
so the potassium sorbate we can write
that as
it's going to be a potassium ion
dissolved in an aqueous solution
plus
the
c6h7o2
this is also going to be an ion
dissolved in the aqueous solution
plus the hydrochloric acid will dissolve
so you have the hydrogen proton
dissolved in the aqueous solution
plus
the chloride
ion or anion i guess we could say it so
that's going to be in
our
aqueous solution and then they react
what happens
well
you're going to have the
c6h7o2 react with the hydrogen proton to
get to sorbic acid so you're going to
have sorbic acid
hc6h
this is a 6 here h7 o2
that's the sorbic acid it's going to be
in an aqueous solution so i took care so
far
of
that
and that and then you're going to have
and then you're going to have your
potassium
ions
your potassium ions and your chloride
it's going to be just like that so this
right over here is the ionic equation
not the net ionic equation i have the
ions on the reaction on the reactant
side and then on the product side right
over here and did i yep i included
everything now when you do the net ionic
reaction you can imagine what's going to
happen here i have potassium ions on the
left i have potassium ions on the right
i could net them out on both sides
so let's net them out on both sides i
have chloride ions on the left i have
chloride ions on the right i can net
them out on both sides and then i can
write the net ionic equation so the net
ionic equation
net
ionic
equation
is going to be
well i have my c6h7o2
ion dissolved in an aqueous solution
you combine that with the hydrogen
proton dissolved in the aqueous solution
and it's going to
it's going to give us sorbic acid
hc6
h7
o2
in our aqueous solution so there you
have it that is the net ionic equation